[Music]
what
is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on we found a part of a man
in the woods today
part of the man i guess the other half
was found
in the mine
oh this has got to be an animal right
no animal that i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belongs to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
it's a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth for you yeah
he is my responsibility
[Music]
he's here
this is our only chance
we have to take it
[Music]
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
here we go
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here the same opinion
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last one standing for
greatness
no one
[Applause]
what is going on
it's okay baby it's okay
it's okay it's okay we're okay we're
okay
okay where where where mom
[Music]
[Applause]
run
[Applause]
i don't know why he came all the way up
here there's nothing left
[Music]
out there worth please
the people that are left another kind of
people worth saving
[Music]
immediate support
captain do you have any idea what those
markers are they look pretty ancient
the tracks end here it's definitely
bravo team they don't just disappear
oh
where the hell are we that lightning it
hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
guys so what
are we like guardians of the galaxy now
on our six
holy sh
did you see that thing
this is officially above my paygrade
i don't care what those creatures are
we destroy them and close the gateway
i'm getting us all home
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from
land and you're descending seven miles
to the bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
all right if we're gonna do this let's
do this
so
from a scale from one to ten how bad's
my rig
we drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
i was deaf turn your lights off
there's something following us
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
and an overpowering urge to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
go fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up doc
don't move let me see it don't move amy
can you see it
okay ready
i love it that's super sweet because
it's terrible
[Music]
the day of the monster uprising
was the day i lost everyone only a small
fraction of humanity survived to move
than a brown
i've been scanning for amy the entire
time
and now i finally found her oh hey amy
is that you oh my
god hey how far is amy's colony
85 miles it's an impossible journey
everything
will try to kill you don't fight just
run and hide
okay
you all alone me too you don't have to
talk about it
you wanna come with me
look down is that a samurai sword yeah
yes it is listen to your instincts out
here man
what if i have terrible instincts
[Music]
you'll die super encouraging speech
you made it all this way for a girl huh
you ever hear the term fools there
we could still take our world back
you're more of a survivor than i thought
oh that was awesome oh i feel like tom
cruise
hey all you shark week fans out there
welcome back
it's our third summer here at little
happy an abandoned fishing village in
the mozambique channel
sharks return here each year their home
like ours
is under attack from climate change
emma what's wrong
a half dozen people went missing about
100 miles up the orange river
turns out it was bull sharks so what do
we do
there is a boy in the field it's big
[Music]
shark
brown where are you there he is
those sharks have been altered engineer
they're not sharp
climate change is making them highly
aggressive towards everything
it's all about survival folks
that was close
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13 i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend a partner
diliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it until it
kills you
he's there
we can get out of this together
[Music]
you